FOR MORE ON THESE
DEVELOPMENTS IN TEXAS
WE GO TO JESSICA WILLIAMS IN THE
STATE CAPITOL, AUSTIN'S
SOUTH BY SOUTH WEST.
JESS, HOW YOU DOING?
>> HEY. HI, I'M GOOD.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: WHAT'S UP?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, JON, I GOT
NEWS FOR DEBBIE RIDDLE.
I SEEN YOU, GIRL, YOU'RE ALL
OH NO, IF TRANSGENER
PEOPLE USE THE BATHROOM, THE
SACRED PLACE WHERE WE PEE
AND DOOKIE WILL BE RUINED NOT
TO MENTION THE CHILDREN.
THE CHILDREN, WHERE WILL
THEY DOOKIE?
BUT, I WILL GUARANTEE
YOU SOMETHING, JON, THAT
LADY HAS USED A MEN'S BATHROOM.
>> WAIT HOW DO YOU -- YOU DON'T
KNOW THAT.
HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
>> BECUSE WE ALL DO.
I'M SURE SHE HAS BEEN TO A
CONCERT.
>> Jon: THIS -- THIS IS DEBBIE
RIDDLE.
>> I'M SURE SHE HAS
PROTESTED AT A CONCERT.
>> Jon: OKAY, THANK YOU.
>> AND THE LADY'S PORT A POTTY
LINE WAS TOO LONG.
SO SHE GRABBED HER MAGIC CONE
AND THEN HIT THE XY BATHROOM.
>> Jon: SHE GRABEED HER -- I'M
SORRY.
>> IT'S A MAGIC CONE, JON. YOU
DON'T LEAVE HOME WITHOUT IT,
YOU JUST CUP, YOU SPRAY AND THEN
YOU WALK AWAY.
BUT JON, IF THIS LAW PASSES, I
AND MILLIONS OF OTHER WOMEN
WILL BE STUCK CHOOSING
BETWEEN A CRIMINAL RECORD
AND A UTI.
>> Jon: BUT THAT, THAT
THING'S JUST A -- WHAT IS THAT A
FUNNEL? IS THAT A FUNNEL.
>> HOW DARE YOU,
JON. IT'S A MAGIC CONE.
>> Jon: OKAY.
>> AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
>> Jon: WHAT?
>> I DON'T HAVE TIME TO
MAN-SPLAIN THIS TO
YOU RIGHT NOW, I HAVE TO GO PUT
THIS THING TO WORK.
SEE YOU LATER.
>> Jon: GOOD LUCK, JESSICA
WILLIAMS.
JESSICA WILLIAMS EVERYBODY!
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK!